uh but we have a lot of news to get to
we begin with some important primary
election results including a major
victory for supporters of abortion
rights they celebrated in kansas last
night after voters rejected a move to
remove abortion right protections from
the state's constitution now this is the
first referendum on the issue since the
supreme court struck down roe versus
wade voters rejected the measure put
forth by republican legislators nearly
60 to 40 percent
caitlin huey burns is in olathe near
kansas city caitlin good morning to you
this result is obviously getting a lot
of attention all all across the country
good morning jerica yes this is a result
that could have national implications
president biden says this makes clear
that a majority of americans support
access to abortion still the results
were a surprise here in kansas because
this is a conservative state donald
trump won it by about 14 points in 2020
but turnout here was huge which suggests
that both republicans and democrats
support access to abortion
a resounding victory for abortion rights
supporters in a conservative state i
feel like my state just showed up and
boldly told me that they are going to
take care of me kansas voters rejected a
ballot measure that would have
eliminated constitutional protections
for abortion in the state a move that
would have allowed the republican
legislature to further restrict or enact
a near ban on the procedure is this the
end can the legislature do anything
on this issue
i think it might be a while before we
get another bite at the apple it was the
first time voters had a direct say on
the issue since roe v wade was
overturned and turnout was significantly
higher than expected for a primary
contest in the state at 47 percent what
was at stake was our constitutional
rights and our freedom and so
you know a coalition of voters across
the political spectrum came together
today and voted no abortion rights
supporters hope the win reverberates
beyond kansas
if you can see that the no votes win
here then that would mean that you could
have that in any part of the country no
matter how red it is so what happens
here in kansas could be a road map for
other states it is a road map for how do
we make sure that we're asserting
defending and protecting the rights of
women to have access to care in any part
of the country
[Applause]
as voters here in kansas decided to
preserve abortion rights at the federal
level president biden is expected to
sign an executive order to expand access
to reproductive care nate
caitlin thank you